It's not just in your head.
When it comes to how we all experience life
bad is generally stronger than good.
We remember trauma more than we remember joy,
we're brought down by criticism more than we're elevated by praise,
and we pay more attention to bad news than good.
A new book called The Power of Bad
by journalist John Tierney and psychologist Roy F. Baumeister
explores the negativity effect,
or the universal tendency for negative events and emotions
to effect us more strongly than positive ones.
The negativity effect shapes everything we do
from our personal relationships, to how we do our careers,
to how we vote, to what media we consume.
But the Power of Bad  isn't just one more cause for despair.
The book's subtitle is 'how the negativity effect rules us and how we can rule it.'
And it offers practical tips on all sorts of ways to approach life
so that we can be happy, productive and well adjusted.
I sat down with John Tierney, a contributing editor at the Manhattan Institute's City Journal
and a former New York Time's columnist and reporter
to talk about the root causes of the negativity effect and how to combat it.